okay hello everyone
uh we're starting a little later than
expected this will probably not run very
long we are looking at
some language completeness and
consistency
uh
items we're starting with system
exception
um right
we started to talk about this last time
and
you know ran out of time and you know
this is somewhat orthogonal
to the discussion of
uh you know exceptions that we had on
monday
so right there's this thing called
system exception which has existed for
20 years
uh
um which
you know
most
the commonly
what happens when malloc fails and at
that point your choices are
give up and abort the computation and
return a system exception or crash and
you know obviously
um
in those cases surely this should be
integrated with the other massive
mechanisms i mean because you can
presumably catch a system exception
yes you catch them yes but i mean but
you can't i mean at the point where
malloc fails you're not going to go
around and generate a stack and
[Music]
uh right do all this other fans
presumably when malik has failed and you
generate a system exception you're
unwinding and getting back to safety
uh well you in a good case yes
but
but
but you're uh right but you're unwinding
right you're back at set you're back in
safety
after you've unround at which point you
can no longer include the stack i get it
i get it so many things you can't many
exception
mechanisms that cannot be done for a
system exception
right system exception is much blander i
don't understand why it can't otherwise
use the same mechanisms but you know
stack is missing not available
um
okay so hold on
the the
right now
if you hit the iteration limit
you don't really want to do here
what does it actually return
well it's what you see right there if if
you're running third well nowadays it
does but it used to return a held
expression right
right
right and you can and you can get the
and for right now and you i mean uh
that's a bigger discussion did not
return those healthy expressions it's
it's slightly i find it i mean we've had
problems in our own code because we've
had code that had a catch
without a tag and a cache without a tag
doesn't catch this
so we looked for exceptions we missed
them because we didn't have the tag
and that's that's another issue is catch
you don't you can't write a catch
that'll catch
tagless and tagged cat throws
well you need a catch inside a catch
which is inconvenient but or
or you could or you could use the
undocumented catch-all let me
don't look at that
okay let me
let me understand
what we're talking about here so for 35
years
it has been the case that in a
you know if i do and i hate doing this
but let me just do it anyway
um
if i say i feel like running a new
version because i really don't want to
crash this version it's not going to
crash it is it
no i say x equals x plus one okay that's
what i get i get a held expression back
okay
now you're proposing that in the new
world i would get a system exception
instead of a held expression yep right
that's a big change
that's a big change
there's tons of documentation of this
it's a big
change world example
is a far cry from what shows up out in
the wild
where recursions spawn inner recursions
i know and a very common result
is a crash or some mix of held and
unheld or who knows what
i don't disagree i'm not i'm not
claiming what's that happening now is
great
i'm not claiming it's good
let me make a comment about this which
is that as we work towards this whole
multi-computation business one of the
features of that is non-terminating
computations we are specifically
this is not the right time to do this to
make this change in my view we are a few
months away from having a much more
sentient model of what to do with
non-terminating computations okay couple
remarks one
by tomorrow i should have a pull request
we put this behind a system option
and by tomorrow i should have a pull
request ready that disables it going
into three one uh 13.1
two i don't care whether it's disabled
hold on danny if it's behind a system
option
um i don't think that would be a bad
thing we can experiment with it but it
certainly shouldn't be on by default
no no it'll be off by default is
whatever right right now it's on by the
there is a system option which is right
now on by default and danny is saying he
it's right since it's just the default
okay
you're going to find out in a few months
that this is really a whole different
world from whatever it is you think
is going to happen with non-terminating
um computations what what this prevents
is crashes from kernel stack exhaust i i
understand that and it's a good thing in
that regard but i want to be make a
unified treatment
of the thing that is returned that
represents what we know about a looping
computation
well that thing is going to be
what's that
i think danny is having internet issues
he warned us that might happen
are you not hearing me we you cut out
you said that thing is and then you're
going to i probably get them used by
mistake
that that thing is going to be a system
option i'm sorry a system exception
whether you call it that or not
that thing that gets returned in deep
recursion or deep iteration no i i
understand and look look listen
i just feel like
we are so close after all these years to
actually having some kind of calculus of
infinite computations but it will be a
mistake
to just go you know cut it's cut it off
right now let's just leave it for one
version put this in behind us
i'm fine with that i was always fine
with that from my own point of view i
want to state it i also think it would
be a shame given that we're so close to
actually solving some of the many many
crash problems that we have
if this just disappears forever
i don't want to despair forever you know
for 13 2 or whatever it is
this thing needs to be there
i just you know i
this discussion right
we are you know the next step in
evaluation graphs is the representation
of the infinite evaluation graphs and so
on as soon as we have something
reasonable to say there you may be right
that it has no relevance to the system
exception business
i'm not convinced of that yet
okay um because what i'm hoping is the
following that a system exception if we
know it's an iteration limit or we know
it's a recursion limit
that it is
um
uh what am i trying to say that it is um
uh
um
you know
we may have some representation
some minimized representation of a
looping computation
and it might be very nice to return that
instead of just saying system exception
of quotes iteration limit
okay there may be a thing that is you
know the equivalent of that but it is
actually a computable infinite
computation a computable width thing
where you can say it's like transparent
numbers where you can combine two and
you can do things like that
compare them etc that may not be
impossible
okay anyway that's my speech on the
subject all right let me
before you go on yeah uh because um
right i i wanted to first offer the
comment that we've already discovered at
least five or six bugs where infinite
recursion was happening but hiding
behind the quiet and with the system
exceptions we found them and fixed them
and now functions are faster because
they're not wasting
at a time triple that number etai okay
that's great yeah um the other thing is
right i mean there is the independent
question of do we want to con document
system exception for the case of malloc
or are we just keeping it
undocumented for now and we'll decide
the its documentation fate in at a later
time
we'll decide it for 13-2 okay soon as
soon as we get i mean this need this has
a timer you know we definitely want this
i just feel like we are just a tiny bit
early and we want to understand infinite
computations a slight bit more
okay okay because i feel like i just
don't know how to represent some of
these things like the difference between
iteration limit and a recursion limit
okay one of them is a pure linear loop
and one of them is some kind of treeing
thing
do you believe that to be correct or not
in in principle that is in
our actual
internal implementation i am not clear
on what exactly causes the iteration
limit
in in the most spectacular failure cases
it's never just a do loop
okay well we need to look that up i mean
we need to try and understand that but i
mean
once we have buried in the past i'm
afraid i mean maybe somebody here
understands that i i i can't no i mean i
think if there's somebody who well maybe
rob is here and understands it but i
mean i think this is the thomas and
pretend i understand it
yeah okay i think i mean if there's
somebody who understands
right okay so back in the infinite
infinite past i'm pretty sure that i
implemented this
originally
right and i'm sure i did it
just as i oh i just don't want it to
crash let me do something here
okay that was probably 1987.
we still don't want to crash i know that
but i don't believe it's been thought
about in the intervening you know 35
years
it has
i made interest to recursion depth
handling uh going back around seven
years ago eight years ago okay fine
but it didn't fix that let me just
explain one point okay about infinite
computations
just to see that there is a different
types there is the
i am an ordinal number
chunk i'm just going down this line
right that is case number one
then there is so x equals x plus one is
such a is such a recursion
okay x equals list x comma x
is not it's a different recursion
it's going to build you know an infinite
binary tree
that makes sense
with a an unknown
you know evaluation order unknown
foliation of the tree
so to speak
okay
i claim those are two different types of
things
and i don't know why it matters that
they're different and perhaps it doesn't
although one of them notably uses memory
and the other does not
right and i there's some classification
of these things which would be useful i
think but i don't really know yet and i
i don't know
you know in the world of transfinite
numbers for example that tree-like
creature
is
somehow a different number
but if you say how many
how many
how many elements are there in that
thing
in the in the first example it's just
omega
i
how many is it
what's that
two to the omega
you think so
for the for the binary branching tree
yeah i mean i would think it was two to
the omega but isn't that
yeah okay well fine but then that's a
different order
so
it's a different order of infinity but
we know for example we can
you know for example
you know as we combine anyway it just
just requires thought which we just
don't have yet
so each of those data structures is
going to correspond to some transfinite
number i claim
and finally 150 years later or something
you know 140 years later finally
transfinite transfers might have a
practical use
anyway
okay let's let's move on here i think i
mean i
i i think it's great that we're putting
in the system exception thing but let's
not put it in by default but let's run
the tests and things with it and so on
make sense
okay
doesn't conjugate either vector
i haven't a clue i don't know anything
about cosine distance
okay
um
right so
i mean
right so right cosine distance is
basically taking uh
um
who's the expert here are you the expert
who's who's the one who's really dug
into this i volunteer rob for that
i mean i i have i i don't have any sense
you know what cosine distance is
actually used for i mean my feeling on
this is we need to make
vector angle and cosine distance
consistent right which i i think i think
i think is the opinion we've now
converged on originally there was some
disagreement about whether we should so
right so there are in fact
five different angles described in the
literature for complex vectors oh god um
and we and we use one of them for vector
angle and
cosine distance should be consistent
with that is my position and i think
we've now i think the others who
initially disagreed uh have have come
along is this a breaking change
i don't think anybody disagreed with the
statement of consistency tai it was just
a question of which definition but but i
think yeah and if cosine distance maybe
can't use all the definitions
you know the vector whatever angle has
to use something consistent with cosine
distance okay yeah right
and so as for use it it's really you
know useful for for certain types of
dendrogram type computation
but not the i mean i don't think anybody
cares about complex values in that
setting
right so so i mean the one issue with
with the definition that that
you know is consistent with our current
vector angle is that it
gives a distance function which is not
real
right it's complex valued
uh it's not good for distance functions
i mean what other distance functions can
be non-real valued
that and correlation distance which
basically has the same definition
okay can we find some
we need more expertise you know the fact
that you say you don't know what it's
used for kind of disqualifies you as far
as i'm concerned from having a real
opinion about
i i kind of disagree with that i think
rob
you know came up with something that's
quite sensible here
unifying the behavior and making them
real valued for
for um
[Music]
so okay so you are claiming metric
all right you are claiming that you're
going to make them real valued
metric-like creatures which i think is a
good thing
and
you know they obey them properties of
metrics that metrics should obey is that
true
even when you feed them complex vectors
no i don't think that's what rob no a
lot of these distance functions we have
are not real metrics
so
no no i mean you've got you know just
take ordinary complex vectors you you
take their inner product you don't
necessarily get a real value
when you take the inner product of the
thing with itself you do
yes right
right so they're behaving more like
inner product type
beasts
all right so anyway you've got a
potential definition
that
ukraine works for complex vectors has
anybody asked roger about this
no
no
edmund on that live stream is suggesting
a method option
which is not unreasonable and certainly
if we're making a breaking change we
should offer that
uh
okay let's ask roger let's make sure we
have some
understanding of the literature which
roger is good at getting
um
you know
is there for example is it broken down
between different fields what people
right right so so so the in these
definitions right
um
right so so what one of these uh the one
that's called the killer angle
is
uh depends only on the plane defined by
the two vectors for example and so that
one is has applications to kayla
geometry hence the name um right the
complex structure
um
you know the pseudo different sorry is
that different from what rob is
proposing that we use yes
yes
then we're going to have a method option
because people are going to care about
kilo geometry
um
so how's that going to work in something
like like distance function where you
give the name of the i mean distance
matrix where you give the name of the
metric
we don't give its name you give a
function
so you can just say
one hash two method arrow blah
yeah fine
i mean it's an obscure case when you're
changing the method
seems to me like what we should do is
try and inventory these methods
and expect to
have different ones
and ask roger for his take on the
literature situation
i i hate to say it but my experience
with dendrogram which does take distance
function goes to cosine distance as an
option
is it doesn't work anyway
so i think we have a bigger problem
ahead of us which is actually getting
functions that should take distance uh
cosine distance to work at well it
doesn't work what do you mean by it
doesn't work i mean i get a slew of
error messages and a garbage output well
then why but why
do i know
okay fine so that's another thing
with the dendrogram code and i i have no
idea what's behind it okay so fine but i
mean you can see what arguments
uh cosine distance is being given and
see why it's complaining
right complaining because the code has
bugs but which code the code of cosine
distance or the code of the underground
well probably dendrogram okay but you
don't know and i mean let's find out
whether cosine distance is being given
garbage or whether cosine distance
itself is complaining i mean
you know clearly we can do this right
now but it doesn't seem like good use of
our time right now
so it seems like this is not fully
cooked go cook it
okay release versus development versions
right so this is some email
that was forwarded to me from roger
by somebody in your office that we
should discuss
and
i don't think there's anything to
discuss but i'm beautifully bringing up
here with my
my argument about why there's nothing to
discuss
okay so the issue is
the currently special most is what is in
development
so the issue is if i just say dollar
version here
okay
great
now if i go to the prototype build well
if you go to the prototype build it'll
say prototype version
okay the issue is but if you go to the
nightly nightly 13-1 build so your your
basic assertion is the point
that there exists a 13-1 build
that
was just made like any other 13-1 build
but suddenly it will be anointed
right is that your basic claim yes
okay so i'm going to make the claim that
it will be at least convenient for some
purposes
if
you know if every non-anointed i think
there's a question for other people
should we in fact burn something in that
says it's not anointed until the moment
when we i see you're saying you will
have already done the test
right
okay right and i've got the codes and
it'll be code signed
okay right with apple
i'm fine fine okay then i've got a
different solution then i think the
solution is we need a simple internal
api
that um uh you can call to find out so
so let's just make an api that we
maintain from the build system where you
can give it a release number and it will
tell you whether it's a development
build or not
yeah i i i'm pr i don't know what it is
but i'm pretty sure that exists and if
you just ask pat rice he will okay so
fine but
let's put that in the internal function
repository and then we're done
okay that's a better solution probably
yep it might have other comments about
it you know maybe it even has comments
about what the status of that build is
and those kinds of things
okay let's talk about lambda for a
second
so i'll just point out that you know
this is a i'm not exactly sure where
this discussion
originated so not everyone here in fact
i'm not entirely sure where it is we're
coming from or what we're trying to
accomplish i do have the comment that we
if we if we're going to add yet another
form for
uh function it probably should be a
matchfix operator
otherwise
you know
you'll always get complaints about
precedences but
interesting
i do agree that yeah match fixing
somehow would be nice
okay can we imagine a way that lambda
could be a matchfix operator
can we imagine a stylized lambda that
could be somehow made matchfix
let's go back to old mathematical logic
okay
you know let's go back to
um gosh i must have this somewhere
um
well let's just see uh
i just got alonzo church's collected
works but it's as a physical book
um
[Music]
i had no idea that london church had
written about so many things about which
one doesn't remember that he wrote about
them and they were very unremarkable
which puts his work on um uh
on lambda calculus into a
okay let's just see what we can find
this here
well you know he was also in the right
place at the right time right he was at
ias with
during no turing was a no that's not
correct he was he was
he was touring was actually a graduate
student with him bizarrely
i mean that is touring went to
you know supposedly alonso church was
alan turing's thesis advisor but alan
turing had already done his you know
okay here we go lambda definability
lambda
okay that's what okay so so what he used
was
lambda a b dot blah blah blah
notably not delimited right
but now what happens when he applies the
lambda to something
oh boy look at that creature
he's putting a brace around the lambda
and then applying it
not beautiful
um
[Music]
and the dot disappeared somehow
well but look at this craziness
look at this absolute freaking craziness
i mean we can't really
you know fault him it was 1935 and they
didn't really understand
a lot of these kinds of things but look
at this this is
a nested lambda
right in which i can't even read this
thing what the heck is this where is
that c is that c
right so that's the local variable right
so it's a function that takes a
oh and returns a fun
or
yeah so but
no i think i think what happened here is
that
the parentheses are a mess
so he doesn't have a
a i don't i've never seen a back a back
end delimiter
for lambdas
um
let's see
okay this is not relevant
uh
the notion of effective calculability
okay
oh that's an exotic what the heck is
that creature
oh we went we weren't german here we
went gothic well as alan turing used to
call them german letters instead of
greek letters
what is that letter anyway
is that a queue maybe
[Music]
emma is asking can lambda be a template
use a template box for its body so
brackets are not needed yes but the
question is what we really like is an
ascii form of the whole thing so you can
type it in so you can type in a function
in a delimited way
what would be a natural way of
delimiting it
i mean here rather crazily he's using
braces around the lambda
just for
i mean that's that's the basic
um
you know so he's outer delimiting it so
to speak and he's got this very exotic
critter
well is that a function or is that
uh an embedding of some kind
um
if f is lambda depend what platform is
okay let's see if there's something else
here
this is just crazy i mean look it
doesn't help like like
whitehead and russell had used dots
instead of parentheses for the limiting
which was completely bonkers
right there i'm starting to feel like
i'm reading less code
yeah well
i mean obviously it's not s expressions
but it's i know and
who was who said this somebody
maybe dennis scott maybe
somebody claimed that john mccarthy had
never actually understood lambdas
um
which casts the whole lisp thing into
even more
confusing okay
um
uh richard is commenting it's as if he
was trying to use operative forms with
those braces
yes arguably
um okay so the question for us is
you know clearly the form lambda sub
whatever or whatever is interesting
i mean it's a nice you know that's a
perfectly nice thing
it's not clear that that's of great
advantage i mean the main given that we
have given that we have pipe dash
greater
you know
right i don't see the advantage of of
that right
over what we are right i admit that this
is a pretty nice form that one there
so
but the real problem that we have with
this one is the lack of
you know is the is the very annoying
thing that we have to go church style so
to speak and do that to apply it right
right i mean the the president
is set up so that right if you assign
that pure function to a variable then
you don't need any parentheses
yeah but that's
look i mean
the difficulty is that almost anything
could come on the right hand side
including plus signs equality all kinds
of things
right so the only question is whether
there's a way
i mean i guess i don't usually do it
this way but i guess you could do this
right you could say x squared plus one
like that
and then if i said
of this
no no i'm toast
yeah
so that's pretty annoying that to apply
the function
i basically have to i mean clearly if
i'm inside a map i don't need any of
that stuff right
right so if you if you right so if you
had slash at i think well
no the slash hat might still be
right if you're
gets captured i mean i i don't yeah i
think yeah i think it does
i mean if i say this if i've actually
got delimited problems i'm in great
shape yep
that's beautiful
the issue is how to apply that
i don't know any form of application i
mean this might just be an idiom right
and right and the problem is that both
at well ad slash ad and especially
bracket have very high precedences right
so if you made it high enough that you
wouldn't need it
around those you basically always need
to parenthesize the right hand side
right but you you never can do
there's no operator
what the heck could you do here
other than something matchfix
and so the the challenge then could
there be is there a tolerable
what would you do i mean with a lambda
how would you end the lambda
is there any reasonable way to end the
lander
uh
our friend alonzo has not helped us here
yeah um
well i was going to say i'm not sure i
actually like the suggestion i'm about
to make but vertical bar is sort of the
some variant of vertical bar is the
least
uh
least bad idea i've had thus far
yeah but you see what the question is is
there any way
well okay actually there is a difference
here look
if we had this
okay
[Music]
at the very least that could work
in a way that i don't know that we care
but that could work precedence wise
um right if if if that lambda has a
higher precedence than bracket
yeah which means you would always have
to use parentheses
oh gosh
right it's the
it's the pattern test problem all over
again
yeah
well then
right
i mean then the other possibility would
be
okay here's a weird idea
no we can't do this
i was going to say
if there was an operator form a function
where where a special lambda
actually just stood for function so you
could write lambda instead just like you
can write you know pi
instead of writing pi
i don't think it really helps you
because you can't subscript
unless
we can make the syntax but it's not
going to help you it's not going to help
you because you still have to dilemmate
the body
right i think i need to run off here but
you know to be continued
we're going to come back to this
um
there any other conventions for landers
languages that have a lambda like
haskell for example do they what do they
how do they delimit the end of the
lambda
anybody know here
i think we need christopher somebody
who's more uh
more of a language uh
fine well let's try to do this like it's
just a backslash
no i understand that that's but that's
the front how does it delimit the oh oh
it has a weird parser right it has some
kind of left to right parser for
everything
we need christopher he knows about this
stuff
okay um
all right good stuff thanks a lot guys
thanks to folks on live stream too and
see you another time